bonjour Jean-Louis Roland bonjour
Frédéric rivière le président ukrainien
est déçu des résultats du sommet de
l'OTAN qui s'est tenu ces deux derniers
jours à Vilnus en Lituanie il demandait
un calendrier clair pour l'adhésion de
son pays à l'Alliance atlantique est-ce
que le temps pouvait satisfaire cette
demande je crois qu'il n'a pas lieu
d'être déçu mais on comprend que dans
l'état de tension où est le président
ukrainien il en veille toujours plus et
qui marque un peu d'humeur quand il n'a
pas exactement ce qu'il veut au moment
où il le veut mais là la situation est
très simple on doit se poser deux
questions est-ce qu'il doit intégrer
est-ce que l'Ukraine pourrait être
protégé doit intégrer un ensemble de
solidarités qui pourrait être l'Union
européenne au titre de Arctic 42,7 qui
organise la solidarité entre les
européens ou le temps le temps est
évidemment préférable et la réponse est
OUI à selon moi et maintenant selon
président de la République dans votre
réflexion c'est l'un ou l'autre ça peut
pas être
c'est de la preuve nous nous sommes dans
les deux mais il peut y avoir la
tentation et cette tentation a été un
peu
suscité par les stimuler par les
Américains qui avaient tendance à dire
oui bah écoutez le temps on verra parce
que les Américains sont beaucoup moins
favorables à l'entrée de l'Ukraine dans
le temps qu'il ne l'était il y a
quelques années par exemple à Bucarest
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt eux qui
traînent les pieds et à l'inverse nous
et les Allemands qui sont plutôt
réticents à Bucarest qui disons NON
écoutez il faut être dans le temps parce
que le carême de 7 de l'Union européenne
ça suffit pas équilibrer la Russie si ça
suffisait à équilibrer la Russie ça
suffirait à défendre l'Europe
occidentale en nous voyons bien que pour
défendre leur occidentale il faut garder
l'Alliance atlantique et pourquoi
voulez-vous que ce qu'il soit vrai pour
l'Europe occidentale ne soit pas vrai
également pour l'Ukraine donc le
principe à mon avis il est là le
glorieux centenaire qui Singer a rappelé
qu'il était très utile que l'Ukraine
soit intégré en revanche pas maintenant
pourquoi pas maintenant parce que il y a
une clause article 5 de le temps qui est
une clause de solidarité militaire très
fort de deux choses une ou la lettre
l'article 5 reste l'être morte et alors
vraiment sa vide le temps de sa
crédibilité ou alors on fait jouer
l'article 5 et on entre tous en guerre
contre la Russie or c'est cela que nous
voulons éviter donc il faut préparer la
les garanties de sécurité de l'Ukraine
pour quand la paix sera revenue et ça
passe sans doute par une forme
d'intégration dans le temps et
l'unski a raison de le dire et nous
avons raison l'appuyer mais pas
maintenant alors en attendant un
véritable fauteuil au sein de l'OTAN une
sorte de strapontin lui a été proposé
avec ce conseil autant Ukraine qui a été
créé qui a tenu sa première réunion à
l'occasion de ce sommet alors je
distrapontin vous reprendriez l'image
non je crois pas que ce soit un bon
temps je crois que les efforts qui sont
consentis par l'ensemble des puissances
occidentales pour aider l'Ukraine à se
défendre sentiment que la grande
décision de l'OTAN hier comme l'a
rappelé le président de la République
dans son communiqué c'est de continuer
de continuer sur le long terme de dire
aux Russes vous ne serez pas quitte de
la solidarité des Occidentaux à l'égard
de l'Ukraine avant longtemps tant que
vous n'aurez pas cessé votre agression
c'est ça la grande nouvelle c'est ça la
bonne nouvelle pour pour Zelinski et
d'autre part plutôt que de se rendre
compte il faut parler effectivement
d'une coordination accrue et organisée
mais l'entrée dans le temps signifierait
l'article 5 donc une entrée en un risque
d'entrer en guerre de l'ensemble des
puissances occidentales nous ne voulons
pas transformer la guerre du crâne en
une troisième guerre mondiale le
ministre britannique de la Défense a
exprimé l'occasion de ce sommet un
certain agacement
du président ukrainien en expliquant
qu'il apprécierait un peu plus de
reconnaissance pour les livraisons
d'arbres nous ne sommes pas Amazon
a-t-il dit en faisant référence aux
géant du commerce en ligne est-ce que ce
risque n'existe pas d'une forme de
lassitude voire d'irritation
à l'égard de l'Ukraine face à des
demandes qui peut-être semblent toujours
plus difficile à satisfaire oui
contrairement à la réputation les
Britanniques ne sont pas toujours
hypocrites et elle a effectivement le
ministre britannique
que ils en ont fait il faut dire qu'ils
en ont fait beaucoup beaucoup les
Britanniques pour les ukaniens et qui
sont fondés à attendre des gestes
reconnaissants mais reconnaissons que le
problème n'est pas là il faut voir elle
inscrit cette nuit il y a eu encore une
attaque de drone qui a provoqué au moins
un mort à Kiev la toute la jeunesse
ukrainienne est exposée et et et et
meurt de façon assez euh beaucoup de
beaucoup de monde actuellement dans dans
la guerre il y a effectivement une une
intensité une nervosité de la part des
Ukrainiens qu'on peut comprendre mais
c'est pas mauvais effectivement de
rappeler que ce que nous faisons pour
l'Ukraine ce n'est pas négligeable et
que ça nous coûte ça nous coûte
budgétairement ça ne coûte militairement
ça nous coûte économiquement les
sanctions etc donc nous faisons des
efforts il n'est pas absolument absurde
de le rappeler le Premier ministre
indien n'arrêtera mody sera demain
l'invité d'honneur des cérémonies du 14
juillet en France l'Inde n'a jamais
condamné l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine
et n'a pas voté de sanction non plus en
septembre dernier à l'Assemblée générale
de l'ONU Emmanuel Macron avait dit les
États qui au nom du non-alignement
refuse de soutenir l'Ukraine sont les
ennemis de la paix mondiale pourquoi
dans ces conditions déroule-t-on le
tapis rouge au Premier ministre indien
je crois qu'il y avait derrière cette
déclaration une illusion selon laquelle
la violation de la Charte des Nations
Unies violations caractérisée massive
injustifiée par la Russie devait
automatiquement entraîner une
réprobation mondiale de tous les états
et on s'est aperçu peu que ça se passait
pas tout à fait comme ça que nous étions
nous puissances européenne nous
occidentaux extrêmement sensibles à cela
mais que d'autres d'autres pays comme
l'Inde par exemple qui n'a pas du tout
approuvé
l'attaque russe l'agression russe contre
pays trouvaient que c'était plutôt c'est
je le regrette parce que c'est une
dimension universelle que c'est plutôt
notre affaire je le regrette mais c'est
ainsi et dans le cas de lin je crois
qu'il faut quand même comprendre que
l'Inde a toujours eu de depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale des relations
privilégiées avec la Russie la Russie la
soutenu face à la Chine
a soutenu et face au Pakistan très
puissamment l'Inde tout au long de son
histoire et puis il faut voir quand même
que nous ne sommes pas que l'un est
quand même un acteur assez à ses
efficace dans la protection des droits
fondamentaux après tout ils sont liés
aux Anglais et aux Américains dans ce
qu'on appelle le quad c'est à dire
impact de vigilance à l'égard des
empiètement de la Chine et deuxièmement
il faut voir les courants de
d'importation de matériel militaire et
civils en provenance de chez nous moi
j'ai été en Inde il y a kayak trois
semaines un mois et ce que j'ai constaté
c'est existait très inquiet par le il
dépendent entièrement des Russes pour
leur armement ils se disent est-ce que
ça va continuer est-ce que les Russes
vont continuer à fournir on n'est pas
sûr est-ce que la qualité des armements
est bonne mais la France fournit des
affaires nous fournissons nous
fournissons des armes on est aussi du
matériel civil vous avez des
commentaires bus absolument massives les
commandes de Rafale et les Américains
d'ailleurs aussi fournissent des arbres
donc je pense qu'il faut avoir une
relation très pragmatique à l'égard de
l'Inde et je me réjouis que le Président
de la République accueille le Premier
ministre indien à l'occasion du 14
juillet merci Jean-Louis brolanche bonne
journée